welcome back attending a las vegas
lights match is like attending a party
it's madness the las vegas lights who
are sponsoring this segment only have a
few home games left this season here to
tell us more about them is the owner
this is brett lashbrook and their mask
mascot cash we know cash how you guys
doing cash the soccer rocker the coolest
mascot in all the professionals really
is amazing so much energy so if someone
hasn't been to a game how would you
describe the energy of the crowd singing
and dancing and cheering uh it is a
little slice of mexico city buenos aires
london and barcelona right here in
downtown las vegas the world's most
popular sport in the world's most
entertaining city perfect match i love
your energy it's contagious every time
we work together i just feel your energy
viva lights everyone
many home games are left so we have
three home games left we have tonight we
have next saturday and then nevada day
october october 30th so get out best
value in all professional sports come on
out tonight experience it and tonight's
la galaxy la galaxy 2 tonight yeah big
game tonight that's it that's the big
rivalry right that is a big rivalry beat
la belle lla get the chat going right
now yes you have something very special
there's always different themes tonight
so tonight we're partnering with the
nevada donor network
wait no there we go right here we're
partnering with the nevada donor network
to raise awareness of the 591 nevadans
that are currently waiting for their
second chance uh through organ donation
right encourage people to be a hero sign
up register to donate your organs uh and
it's especially true in the local
hispanic community right there's a lot
of demographics that go into this uh and
there is a need especially in the
hispanic community so we want to bring
we can bring awareness tonight our
players will be wearing this all game
long a special jersey to raise awareness
for the cause you guys are always doing
good that you're always giving back to
last year that's what i've learned about
you appreciate that now we have a chant
right do i have the chant rights i know
there's a chin at the game there is a
chance at the game yes is it augie augie
okay
toyota right uh did his own entry
recorded his own song those of you that
don't know john barr will do anything to
sell you a car but also as an old rock
and roll guy over in england he recorded
our own intro song that we played every
game so you got to come out tonight best
value in sports and experience it what
are some of the other things that happen
at the game is there a swimming pool
there for people we've got we've got
swimming pools on the sidelines we shoot
off more confetti when we score a goal
than what you'd see at the super bowl
smoke dude we've got we've got smoke
we've got drums we've got you can drive
your toyota onto the onto the pitch and
park behind the bench hold on there are
all kinds of things like that you can
just drive it out there absolutely you
can park your car on the field behind
the bench that's how great it is when
are we doing ted lasso night
next year
it's on the radar it's on the radar this
is the man to talk to because this is
the owner of our las vegas lights we
love you guys so much and everything you
do for the community everyone come on
out tonight you're making a decision
right now on your couch what you want to
do tonight come on out you won't
disappoint viva lights viva lights cash
man field is where the game is our las
vegas lights fc pro soccer uh for
tickets you can call at 702-728-4
or just go to
lightsfc.com rocky over to you thank you